كيف
نفهم يعني شروع الاحتلال في تسخين جبهه لم
تكن ملتهبه بالقدر الذي نراه في قطاع غزه
وهو بالكاد يستطيع اداره المعركه في قطاع
غزه وقد سحب مؤخرا عددا من الالويه واعاد
جنودا من الاحتياط الى انعاش الاقتصاد
الاسرائيلي الذي يعني يئن حسب محللين من
وط تكاليف هذه
الحرب يعني بالتاكيد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
غير قادر على ان خض حربا على جبهتين جبهه
قطاع غزه التي يتعثر فيها بالصوره الظاهره
الان والتي اقر الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
لسان قيادات في الجيش الاسرائيلي بالاضافه
الى قدر الظاهر من التذمر في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بحاله الانهاك التي ييها الجيش
الاسرائيلي داخل قطاع غزه المؤشرات
والمعطيات حول ذلك كثيره وبالتاكيد
بالضروره هو غير قادر على ان يخوض حربا
يعني في جبهه اخرى لكن دعنا ننظر الى
الموضوع من زاويه اخرى في الحقيقه ربما
يعني نحن نهتم بان نعقل
تصرفات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان نبحث عن
اسباب منطقيه او مسوغات منطقيه لتصرفات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكن في الحقيقه الذي
نلاحظه منذ عمليه س7 تشرين اكتوبر حتى هذه
اللحظه والاحتلال الاسرائيلي بقدر كبير من
تصرفاته لا يتسم بالعقلانية
تراعي الاعتبارات الاستراتيجيه وتراعي
الاعتبارات السياسيه الى حد كبير لكن واضح
تماما ان اللطمه التي تعرض لها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الخلخله التي تعرض لها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الهيبه التي فقدها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على المستوى
الفلسطيني وعلى مستوى المنطقه بالاضافه
الى الاسباب الشخصيه المتعلقه ببنيامين
نتنياهو الذي اصبح مستقبله السياسي في مهب
الريح ايضا المستقبل المهني لجنرالات
الجيش هذه ليست عمليه بنيامين نتنياهو فقط
هذه عمليه المؤسسه الاسرائيليه كلها على
المستوى السياسي وعلى المستوى العسكري
وعلى المستوى الامني اعتقد ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لا يفكر في بعض الاحيان بصوره
عقلانيه في سياسات وممارسات من هذا النوع
بالتاكيد للاحتلال الاسرائيلي حساب مع
الشيخ صالح العروره هو يهدد باغتيال الشيخ
صالح العروره قبل عمليه 27 اكتوبر منذ ان
تصاعدت حاله المقاومه داخل الضفه الغربيه
وحمله المسؤوليه عن ذلك ثم بعد عمليه 27
اكتوبر صار الاحتلال يتحدث ان قيادات حماس
غير امنين في اي مكان في هذا العالم
وبالتاكيد ايضا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اذاء
حاله التعثر التي يعانيها في قطاع غزه
يبحث عن صوره انتصار وبدله انه بامكانه ان
يرسل طائره
مسيره لتنفيذ عمليه الاغتيال هذه في لبنان
لكن اذا اردنا ايضا ان نفكر بصوره يعني ان
كان الاحتلال قد فكر بصوره عقلانيه ام لا
من غير المستبعد ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يريد ان يعيد الولايات المتحده بعد ان
اخذت حامل طائراتها وذهبت من هذه المنطقه
يريد ان يعيدها الى المنطقه من جديد منذ
البدايه سعى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى ان
يورط الولايات المتحده للقيام بمعركه
وبحرب النيابه عنه للاحتلال اسرائيلي
حسابات يريد ان يصفيها مع القوى المعاديه
له الموجوده في الاقليم اذا كنا نتحدث عن
ايران او اذا كنا نتحدث عن حزب الله ولكنه
بالتاكيد هو غير قادر ان يخوض هذه المعركه
وحده او ان يخوض اكثر من معركه على اكثر
من جبهه وبالتالي من غير المستبعد ان
بنيامين نتنياهو وربما كل المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه تريد ان تورط الولايات
المتحده في معركه بحيث يتفرغ الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي للمقاومه في قطاع غزه ثم يتوقع
ربما يجر الولايات المتحده لمعركه على
لبنان او لمعركه على ايران او ما شابه m